trump incites mob was the headline in
today's new york times the washington
post meanwhile comes in with
trump mob storms capital and that pretty
much captures how it went here yesterday
in the waning days of president trump's
term
as the house and senate were inside
counting electoral votes
thousands of supporters of the president
smashed their way
into the building behind me forcing
lawmakers into shelter
and pretty much having their way with
the capitol building until law
enforcement could retake it
four people died including one who was
shot by capitol police
and i do not say the following lightly
president trump inspired this violence
through his false claims of election
fraud including
including at a rally here yesterday in a
statement this morning he is promising
a quote orderly transition however he
continues to falsely claim the election
was stolen
and cbs news has learned some members of
his cabinet have discussed
invoking the 25th amendment to remove
him from
office chris van cleave was at the
capitol yesterday and this morning he is
about 14 blocks up
from my location on pennsylvania avenue
between the white house and the capitol
building where i'm standing chris good
morning to you you were covering this
from early to late what's the scene
there now
tony there is a bitter breeze this
morning
and in icy quiet now that's very
different than the chilling scenes
we saw yesterday as the capital one of
the symbols of american democracy
essentially came
under attack as tens of thousands of
trump supporters
descended upon it egged on by the
president and his baseless claims of
election fraud
as those supporters of the president
tried to bring their
message directly to congress
we're willing to rest our lives
in extraordinary hours of chaos in the
capital
angry supporters of president trump
breached the branch of government
set to put the final seal on his
november election loss staying in recess
until the call of the chair both houses
of congress were in session as violent
protesters smashed
and bashed their way in
ripping off heavily fortified doors and
climbing through windows
vice president pence and all 100
senators were whisked to safety
as members of the mob pushed back police
clashing in the capitol
armed with anything they could find then
entering an
inner sanctum of the u.s government not
open to the public since before the
pandemic
posing for pictures on the abandoned
senate dice
and with feet on a desk in the office of
house speaker nancy pelosi
leaving this note we will not back down
[Applause]
huddled in the house chamber members of
congress hid anywhere they could
shots are being fired inside the capitol
chamber check to make sure the doors
that
were near me were locked i checked them
i started to leave the chamber
and started to hear pop pop shots
york congressman tom swazi captured the
chaos on his cell phone
just evacuated from the chambers these
are people who would have been detained
i saw dozens of capitol police with
their weapons drawn
guns trained on the door armed officers
held off an angry mob
behind this barricaded door
from reaching the house floor when a
woman tried to climb through a window
police fired air force veteran ashley
babbitt wrapped in a trump flag
fell to the floor and later died just a
day earlier babbitt tweeted nothing will
stop
us three others died of medical
emergencies on the capitol grounds
outside hundreds scaled the scaffolding
set up for president-elect biden's
inauguration
and unfurled trump flags the assault on
the capitol started only about an hour
after president trump urged supporters
to march to the capitol at his save
america rally
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
you have to show strength and you have
to be strong
eventually tactical teams repelled the
rioters from the capitol
though only dozens were arrested you got
into the capitol i was on the front line
boyd camper told us he made it to the
capitol rotunda
we're going to take this damn place if
you haven't heard it's called
the insurrection act and we the people
are ready
those images are still unbelievable now
the bomb squad was called to the
republican national committee
headquarters which isn't very far from
the capitol yesterday
because two devices that looked to be
pipe bombs were found
outside the building also nearby was a
vehicle with ammunition
firearms and apparent bomb making
materials now the fbi has launched a
website they are
asking people to send pictures and video
as they try to
find the people responsible for the
violence yesterday
and tony it is hard to think about a
protest in washington i've covered so
many of these
there are big questions here where was
the police presence earlier in the day
and
you know four people lost their lives
protesting what was essentially a
procedural
process in inside the capital it was not
really law making anything but but
process
it's typically a formality and we will
get to those questions later in the show
chris van cleef for us as dawn breaks
over his shoulder there